[Musique]
gilles legendre président du groupe des
députés en marche c'est l'invité
d'auditions publiques bonsoir gilles
legendre bonsoir michel grossiord et
merci d'être avec nous donc présents à
ce rendez-vous de public sénat de la
chaîne parlementaire assemblée nationale
de la fp et du figaro d'ailleurs les
internautes qui nous suivent sur le site
du journal peuvent réagir via le chat du
figaro et poser leurs questions et bien
sûr je me ferais le relais de vos
interrogations avec moi ifria rayonne
pas ce cadre boulevard tout à l'heure
brigitte boucher et oriane mancini et
dans un instant les parlementaires david
habib député socialiste et alain
joyandet sénateurs et l'air seront
également avec nous pour vous
interpeller sur un certain nombre de
sujets gilles legendre vous avez été
reçu ce matin par emmanuel macron dans
le cadre des rencontres du chef de
l'état avec les présidents des groupes
parlementaires
alors vous êtes le président du groupe
majoritaire à l'assemblée
vous avez donc la possibilité
peut-être de demander d'exiger de
contester certains aspects de la
politique comment s'est déroulé cet
entretien quelle a été la teneur
d'abord forcément très cordiale vous en
doutez il ya un élément de compagnonnage
quand on rencontre le président de la
république un compagnonnage respectueux
mais un compagnonnage réel nous avons
tous et le président de la république en
tête conscience que nous vivons un
moment clé dans notre vie démocratique
et à un moment clé du quinquennat du
quinquennat mais plus largement de notre
vie démocratique
le grand débat national doit déboucher
sur un certain nombre de propositions
qui vont permettre au pays d'accélérer
sa transformation
mais aussi de faire évoluer ses
pratiques démocratiques et pouvoir ce
débat est ce qu'on en sort alors il ya
un mot qui revient régulièrement à fr un
homme est ce qu'on en sort par un
référendum
vous n'avez pas l'air très chaud pour ça
vous alors ce que j'ai dit ce matin
c'est que ça n'était pas le sujet du
moment n'ont en revanche et ce qui
devait vous répondre non pas du tout je
suis très mauvais au football alors donc
je serai très mauvais à l' esquive aussi
alors je sors j'ai 20 ans j'ai entière
de la crise rige et 10 au mois de
décembre j'ai même écrit au président de
la république que très probablement il
faudrait que le grand débat national se
termine par une initiative politique
forte et que le référendum était
probablement une initiative politique
forte possible non je n'ai pas dit ça
alors j'ai dit que aujourd'hui
présentement ce n'est pas la priorité la
priorité c'est de savoir jusqu'où nous
poussons l'ambition dans la
transformation de nos pratiques
démocratiques mais c'est quoi ça oui ça
veut dire quoi
ce gage et viager les jeunes ça veut
dire qu'on revient ça veut dire comment
nous associons de façon beaucoup plus
étroite les français à la manière dont
ils sont gouvernés ce qu'on appelle en
jargon la démocratie participative où la
démocratie directe
les deux ne se confondant pas d'ailleurs
car la démocratie directe tout le monde
en parle notamment à l'occasion du
référendum
d'initiative citoyenne ou du référendum
d'initiative partagée auquel je suis
également favorable
mais c'est aussi la démocratie indique à
gérer sont les associés les jambes
on ne peut pas faire de démocratie
participative si on ne change pas notre
constitution il faut changer la
constitution préalablement pour cela il
ferait à la démocratie participative ça
n'est pas que la constitution saleh par
exemple si on modifie les règles du
référendum d'initiative partagée
j'y suis favorable sens et j'y suis
moins favorable 18 - lavaur av
où ça l'est aussi pour la constitution
quand on va faire évoluer le conseil
économique social et environnemental
mais il ya beaucoup de choses qui ont
trait à notre vie démocratique et qui ne
passe pas par la constitution
dans l'exemple ci si je prends l'exemple
nous avons une force dans notre pays ce
sont nos associations et des
associations qui luttent contre la
pauvreté qui luttent pour le handicap
qui luttent sur les questions
d'immigration war
ces associations elles jouent un rôle
fondamental dans notre pays comme on les
associe de plus près au fonctionnement
démocratique
pareil sur les syndicats on pourrait
revenir vous les avez négligé non mais
c'est difficile laurent berger le
premier à se plaindre du mépris pour les
corps intermédiaire à laurent berger est
venu deux fois devant groupes
parlementaires et les deux fois c'était
à mon initiative
gilles legeard n'y a pas que des
réponses institutionnelles parce que ça
c'est de l'organisation aussi mais ils
vont aussi vous dire les gilet jaune
on voudrait et bien augmenter le smic on
voudrait vous reveniez sur l'impôt sur
la fortune
on voudrait vous reveniez sur certaines
niches fiscales qu'est ce que vous leur
dites et bien j'attends que nous ayons
l'ensemble des propositions et savent
portera et les transformations que nous
opérons à la suite du grand débat
national porteront la trace de ces
propositions mais nous l'avons dit
d'emblée tout ce qui a été proposé ou
aura été proposé dans le grand débat
sera publié et public
il n'y aura pas de sens sud est mais
ensuite nous prendrons nos
responsabilités aura les trains seule
revendication les traces de nivelles pas
simplement les traces parce que dia 78%
des français sur un sondage récent qui
veulent un changement de politique
économique qu'est ce que vous dites que
cela
eh bien nous verrons de quelle
changement il s'agit s'il s'agit par
exemple pour ce que vous avez parlé de
sf
s'il s'agit par exemple daste aurait une
meilleure justice fiscale dans ce pays
nous y sommes prêts et nous souhaitons
vêtements nous savons que c'est un sujet
sensible parce que publiera demain à
proposait de moduler les niches fiscales
est ce que c'est une piste intéressante
c'est une piste parmi d'autres mais vous
voulez ma conviction mais justifie ce
qu'a à voir sur quoi vous vous engager
concrètement ne pense certainement pas
le 4 février pour un débat national dont
jusqu'au grade et marvic sion non-sujet
ses convictions alors j'ai des
convictions ambitions alors messieurs
puis laissez moi le temps voulu des
convictions sur l'inégalité fiscale dont
on parle beaucoup est-ce qu'il faut
créer de nouvelle tranche d'impôts sur
les hauts revenus ou pas quel est votre
tête je promenais qu'en matière de
justice fiscale il faudra agir sur une
multitude de levier cela fera les oui il
est désolé keim lesquels lesquels on
peut jouer sur l'impôt sur le revenu on
peut jouer sur les mots on peut jouer
sur la peur est certaine et les
adhérentes et je n'étais on échoue en
écouter proposition normalement jouer
sur la fiscalité locale
aujourd'hui notre système fiscal souffre
un d'une très grande complexité qui le
rend en apparence irréformable et deux
d'une certaine forme d'inégalité qui
fait qu'aujourd'hui les français ne le
supportant l'ubs fait vous attendez un
chamboule tout je pense qu'en matière
fiscale il va falloir s'engager sur un
pacte de réformes fiscales gang un big
bang maison volante mais mais mais
n'attendez sur longue période
nous ne changerons pas le système fiscal
en six mois c'est un mensonge pour ceux
qui font six ans j'ai le temps dans
votre partie parce que les
téléspectateurs le demande
il y a une piste qui coûte cher
d'ailleurs à la collectivité mais qui
est utile en termes d'emploi c'est celui
des emplois domicile c'est une niche
fiscale
vous savez quand vous employez quelqu'un
vous déduisez est bien de vos impôts une
certaine somme est ce que par exemple on
pourrait imaginer que le gouvernement
revienne sur cette niche fiscale qui
profite à on va dire aux classes
supérieures super moyenne supérieure à
seulement aux classes moyennes
supérieures et notamment aux seniors
pour nous avons d'ailleurs envisagé
et nous avons d'ailleurs renforcé cet
avantage fiscal en direction des seniors
parce que c'est une des conditions de
leur maintien à domicile donc là vous
voyez on a l'exemple même d'une niche
qui a une vertu et une utilité sociale
mais on ne fera pas le travail niche par
niche en disant on est pour on est
content ce sera une vision d'ensemble
que nous devons avoir en matière fiscale
qui viendra que grandir ah ben quand
même donc sa big bang fiscal d'un deuil
pense que 2022 et peut-être au-delà ah
oui vous savez ces îles et il l'est de
la fiscalité comme d'un nombre
incalculable de domaines de l'action
publique et qui explique en grande
partie la colère des gilet jaune
on a reculé devant les grandes réformes
devant les grandes transformations soit
parce qu'elle était trop compliqué soit
parce qu'elle coûtait trop cher
soit parce qu'elles étaient impopulaires
il faut maintenant aller dans le vif
d'un certain nombre de sujets sur la
réforme de l'action publique de la
fiscalité de la réforme de l'état de la
réforme des administrations
c'est ça l'objet du grand débat national
c'est de faire en sorte que les
françaises puissent s'exprimer sur ces
sujets et le moment venu nous déciderons
donc voilà crise majeure celle des
gilets jaunes répondre à un big bang
fiscal
on craint de pascal question peut-être
supplémentaires oui on voit que vous
avez votre prise
michel eeckhout et oui j'essaye de
chercher fort et marquant dans vos rangs
ça ça phosphore beaucoup autour de ces
idées de fiscalité et jean-françois
cesarini a proposé par exemple de
refaire payer leur isf à ceux qui font
dormir leur argent est ce que c'est une
piste que vous écarter ou est-ce que
vous accueillez par principe à ce moment
du grand déballage verra de thé nous
n'écartons rien nous sommes là pour
débattre
écoutez je dois dire très franchement je
n'ai pas encore eu l'occasion d'en
discuter avec jean françois
je n'ai pas très bien compris sa
proposition l'argent qui dort
je vois la dimension mythique que
représente l'expression en termes
concrets pratique je le vois moins donc
il va m'expliquer ce qu'il a derrière la
tête
et puis nous en discuterons nous allons
vous savez je inaugure demain une série
de quatre grands débats correspondant
aux quatre chapitres du grand débat
national à l'intérieur du groupe et
demain nous parlons des institutions
mais nous parlerons ensuite de la fisk
et les chasseurs et les différents
membres du groupe pourront faire valoir
leur peau
disons exactement comme dans le grand
débat national est pas peur que tout ça
au sein de votre groupe mais je ne veux
pas de votre habileté pour le maintenir
unis mais que finalement on entend les
uns les autres sur beaucoup de sujets et
bien que d'une poignée de frondeurs un
jour qui se manifestent et que du coup
et bien vous ayez autant de difficultés
que du temps de françois hollande alors
je vais vous reprendre sur un point on
ne gouverne pas un groupe parlementaire
avec de l'habileté avec de l'autorité
avec de la sincérité de la confiance et
un brin d'autorité oui et c'est ce que
j'espère c'est ce que j'essaye de 2 à
domicile
écoutez ça marche pas si mal mettez de
citez moi une loi qui n'a pas été voté
et nestea témoin une loi qui n'a pas
fait l'objet d'un enrichissement très
puissant très profond alors par demong
au parlement sur un point justement dans
le cadre du grand débat puisqu'il y en a
un qui dans grands débats et bien parle
beaucoup c'est gérald darmanin et il dit
voilà ils veulent les payer moins
d'impôts les gilets jaunes et les
français en général ce qui est tout à
fait normal mais ils veulent aussi les
mêmes services publics est il du barreau
va de façon sans leur faire payer
évidemment le renvoyer tous les mois la
facture où tous les ans la facture des
services publics
ce que ça coûte aux contribuables sans
évidemment les faire payer
est ce que vous êtes d'accord avec cette
idée qui rendrait lisible l'action
publique mais ça je trouve que ce n'est
pas une mauvaise idée mais moi je
considère que non seulement les français
ont raison de vouloir payer moins
d'impôts mais ils sont en droit en même
temps d'exiger des services publics de
meilleure qualité
c'est précisément parce qu'on a fait
l'un verse depuis 30 ans des plus
d'impôts plus de dépenses publiques plus
de déficit plus de dettes pour en face
des services d'une qualité et d'un accès
de plus en plus inégalitaire
cette équation là nous devons l'inversé
on suit darmanin on comprend qu'on peut
pas faire mieux et plus 6 mois ci et si
vous êtes si magicien non c'est non vous
savez michel grossiord toutes les
entreprises se réorganise de cette
manière là il n'y a pas de raison que
l'entreprise et à échappent à cette
règle
il y a des moyens de produire du service
public aujourd'hui avec moins de coûts
et une
leur efficacité est notamment avec ce
que j'appelle moi le bénéfice citoyen
qu'est ce qu'attend le citoyen d'un
service public dans les zones rurales
ayant de la présent et ben voila et bien
on peut instaurer de la présence et on
peut le faire avec notamment le
numérique avec l'organisation leur
pardon le regroupement des services dans
des lieux uniques qui permet d'organiser
des permanences
il y à mille façons d'améliorer la
qualité du service public sans augmenter
les impôts
c'est exactement ce à quoi nous avons
commencé de nous engager et que va faire
apparaître le grand débat comme une
exigence fondamentale de nos concitoyens
parce qu'à la question est ce que vous
êtes satisfait de la façon dont ce grand
débat est engagé vous semblez déjà un
peu anticipé sur ces conclusions
justement c'est vous qui demandez
d'anticiper au contraire je ferai moi
car l'association vous à vos
propositions vous mais des propositions
le groupe les produira en son temps
c'est à dire aux alentours du 15 mars
il valait construire ensemble ça sera
d'ailleurs des propositions des grandes
lignes des grands principes sur lequel
nous avons envie de nous engager en tant
que député pour répondre à votre
question
le débat est un immense succès
les français y adhèrent massivement et
les dépôts et les députés bien sûr vous
allez sur vous avez déçu bien sûr mais
bien sûr j'en ai encore un vendredi
prochain dans la mairie du 5e je suis
parisien alors les débats sont pas
exactement de la même nature mais tous
nos collègues sont profondément engagés
je prends l'exemple de nadia est député
trappe qui a organisé un débat avec 200
personnes dans une zone pas très simple
dont on disait qu'elle avait du mal à
adhérer les gens de plus de plutôt
favorables à la république en mon nom et
avec tous les cas la super équipe à six
mais je les ai vus avec vous on leur a
donné des abats fait attention à soi
raconte ma copine il y avait tout le
monde sait qu aux cérémonies le magnat
mais on dit on dit vous dites c'est un
formidable succès pour emmanuel macron
non nous instrumentaliser seront jamais
des plus utiles ce débat là non mais si
longtemps quand même qu'ils aient fait
nous aimons cette manipulation
qu'est ce qu'on attendait expliquez-moi
pourquoi des centaines de milliers de
personnes écrivent sur internet leurs
propositions écrivent expliquez moi
pourquoi des milliers de réunions ont
lieu est bon c'est bon on a fêté envoyé
la police pour aller chercher les gens
on n'a forcé personne et il ya des gens
de toutes opinions et d'ailleurs y
compris dans les débats publics auxquels
a participé le chef de l'état vous avez
vu que la contestation
ils y allaient bon train donc ce ne sont
pas des débats mais est ce que c'est une
opportunité parce que finalement les
maquereaux nistre retrouve un petit peu
l'esprit de leur campagne
c'est là sans doute n'en on retrouve nos
codes génétiques ça fait plaisir et ça
c'est vrai vous avez l'impression de le
faire d'ailleurs pour ça que ça marche
et c'est pour ça que nos troupes s'y
engagent
j'ai donné l'impression de repartir en
campagne alors que non je suis être une
deuxième reprise n'est pas une campagne
que nous lance gilles legendre
si d'aventuré il y avait un référendum
je sais que tout n'est pas encore
complètement décidé et définitif ça
pourrait être le 26 mai et or le 26 mai
des élections européennes
est ce qu'on pourrait imaginer cumuler
un référendum avec une élection
européenne à référendum caractère
national avec une élection qui était par
l'éclosion honda est ouvert sur cette
question je pense que chacun a le droit
d exprimer ses convictions ou mes
convictions rayant cette voie très chaud
et bien je suis assez de leur avis oui
je pense que ce n'est pas forcément une
bonne idée mais je n'en fais pas une
question de principe et vous n'avez pas
peur que en dehors de tout cette
élection européenne soit un peu
cannibalisé par l'agitation qui je ne
crois pas du tout à du tout je crois
qu'on est en train de restaurer le goût
de la politique dans notre pays mais
l'ajustement mobilisés dans les yeux des
gens qui vous font un style qui vont
venir répondre aux références vous
extractives ont alimenté le buzz car les
éleveurs explique que en ouvrant le
grand débat nour el nour et ouvrons
l'intérêt de nos concitoyens pour la
politique
et cet intérêt se porte sur le grand
débat il sortira peut-être un jour s'il
ya un référendum sur le référendum
il se portera de très près sur les
décisions qui découleront du grand débat
mais cet intérêt bénéficiera aux
élections européennes
faire un dôme il ya il sera bénéfique à
l'enjeu européen
je ne dis pas que c'est le référendum
lui-même jeudi le grand débat lui même
le grand départ ouvre l'appétit des
français pour la politique et ça c'est
une chose excellent qui profitera à
plein d'autres choses qu'au grand débat
y compris aux élections alors il ya
d'autres revendications justement n'y a
pas que le référendum en entend pas sûr
sur le pouvoir d'achat notamment qu'est
ce que qu'est-ce qu'on peut donner comme
signal en la matière à écouter on vient
d'en donner un grand pouvoir d'achat je
rencontrais des responsables de la
banque de france vendredi nous aurons la
plus forte hausse du pouvoir d'achat en
france en 2010 neuf jamais rencontrés
depuis plus de 15 ans grâce à grasse
grave grâce notamment aux mesures
d'urgence économique et social no mais
pas seulement puisque un certain nombre
de mesures avaient déjà été en retrait
de 500 euros comment ça peut être ce
soir
non attendez il ya plus un ennemi entre
un ennemi et 2% de hausse du pouvoir
d'achat
concentré précisément sur les
populations qui en ont le plus besoin et
qui tombe qui ont exprimé le plus de
revendications sur certaines dans le
cadre de nous aimer les jeux en 1881
est-ce que de ce point de vue il ya il
est il ya une question qui est sur la
table aussi c'est l'augmentation du smic
ça coûte cher
le président de la république est plutôt
allé vers la prime d'activité par plutôt
clairement car membres est une idée
originale est ce qu'on pourrait imaginer
une régionalisation du smic
sachant quand vous habitez peau et que
vous habitez paris vous n'avez pas du
tout le même mode de vie les mêmes
obligations en termes de logement de jeu
le déplacement gleick formidable acteur
du débat national il ferait a posté
cette proposition sur la plate forme et
je suis sûr qu elle recueillera
énormément l'approbation ça peut faire
partie d'une évolution intéressante
pourquoi pour trouver qui est
intéressant c'est un terreau
régionaliser c'est clair clairement une
piste qui peut être intéressante
ce qui est important dans la hausse du
smic et c'est la raison pour laquelle
nous avons préféré la prime d'activité
c'est que nous ne devons rien faire qui
bride la compétitivité des entreprises
la base de tout et notamment du pouvoir
d'achat ce sont des entreprises
compétitives qui sont capables de créer
de la richesse
dernière minute
cette première partie qui est le genre
avec la question d'un de pascal oui
parmi les autres demandes un peu
institutionnel il ya la question d'une
dissolution de l'assemblée
qu'en pensez vous et également l'idée
d'un changement de premier ministre
edouard philippe pour que vous
connaissez bien est-ce que vous pensez
que pour donner un nouvel élan
si je dis que je trouve que la
dissolution est une hypothèse assez
fantaisiste vous allez dire que je suis
juge et partie le général de gaulle
avait choisi un oui aujourd'hui il enfin
attendez nous ne sommes pas du tout dans
le même scénario de crise et je ne suis
pas sûr du tout que ça change quoi que
ce soit au fonctionnement démocratique
du pays
nous allons réformer le fonctionnement
démocratique du pays nous allons
continuer et accélérer un certain nombre
de grandes transformations pour répondre
aux besoins concrets des français et
notamment les plus vulnérables et les
plus fragiles d'entre eux je ne vois pas
en quoi la dissolution changerait quoi
que ce soit quant au premier partiel
canton arsenal a cru mais nous allons
mais nous allons très probablement voter
la proportionnelle blanc j'y ai joué
mouvement anti macro et l'anti la
république en marche
je pense que le mouvement gilet jaune
c'est un mouvement anti système
antisystème et nous sommes nombreux à
être visé par cette critique et cette
contestation journal voulait dire nous
aussi on appelle ça vous allez arrêter
longtemps journaliste merci mais c'est
pour ça que j'aurais passé ma vie à être
contestées merci beaucoup maintenant
entrer en piste de deux parlementaires
que je vous annonçais tout à l'heure
bonsoir messieurs donc alain joyandet
sénateurs et l'air de haute saône et
david habib député socialiste des
pyrénées-atlantiques bonsoir merci à
tous les doutes à une question d'un
internaute du figaro c'est jean-paul qui
vous demandent ils le genre est ce que
vous constatez par des statistiques que
le phénomène de ruissellement attendus
ou annoncé justifie par exemple les
allégements fiscaux l'impression dieu
savait ce que vous le constatez une
question de jambes le mot de
ruissellement nous ne l'avons jamais
utilisé parce qu'il ne correspond à
aucune réalité ni les théories
économiques
ce que nous constatons c'est que depuis
que nous avons allégé la fiscalité de
l'épargné l'investissement repart
fortement très fortement que les
entreprises se remettent à créer se
remette à créer des emplois et que les
investissements étrangers en france
accélère dans des proportions que nous
n'avions jamais observée tout ça ce dont
sept se sont des facteurs qui vont
positivement qui vont dans un sens
positif pour l'économie
alors on va parler d'économie notamment
mais pas seulement
première question david habib oui sur
l'économie ce que tu viens de dire
gilles et des fous alors on peut se
vouvoyer dans les studios que ce vous
voyez à dans l'hémicycle je suis libre
en tout état de cause ça se voit pas sur
l'immobilier et les chiffres de
l'immobilier ont montré qu'ils avaient
une baisse des investissements a de
façon spectaculaire une baisse à la fois
de la construction une baisse des
investissements
quant à l'industrie moi je suis et l'élu
d'un territoire industriel et ya pas un
seul projet industriel depuis qu
emmanuel macron est devenu président la
république est associée pas les deux
mais en tout état de cause c'est
peut-être vrai dans le 16e
arrondissement qui est une terre où il
ya effectivement beaucoup d' usine ça
l'est moins vrai ce complexe de lacq
n'est pas territoire arrondissement à
bord dont je ne suis pas député du
sésame d'entrée son pari sinon havrais
sont pas des rognons qu'il faut adresser
il faut arrêter de croire que les choses
sont depuis 2010 est son taux au bleu et
voyez ça je n'ai pas dit ça david
d'autre que l'investissement redémarrer
et ça n'est pas moi qui le dit c'est
l'insee c'est toutes les enquêtes toutes
les entreprises qui le disent
elles ont des projets et sont en train
d'investir alors il se peut et c'est à
dire un des sujets problématiques que
nous devons résoudre qu'il ya une grande
inégalité des territoires et ça je suis
à l'admettre parce que c'est une réalité
il y a aussi une grande inégalité entre
les tailles des entreprises qui
investissent c'est la raison pour
laquelle depuis 20 mois
nous investissons en majorité sur les
pme la loi pacte que nous avons hâte de
pouvoir voter définitivement ira
exactement dans ce sens là donc certes
il ya des territoires qui souffrent nous
le savons parfaitement mais c'est vrai
aussi en matière d'emploi et des
territoires qui ont deux et demi 3 % de
chômeurs et des territoires cantons 35
c'est le drame français alors j'ai la
phrase d'alain joyandet que nous devons
résoudre
je voudrais revenir sur la justice
fiscale parce que là vous parlez la
justice territoriale enfin des
inégalités territoire sont 1 il ya aussi
mais il ya aussi les inégalités fiscales
vous avez quand même commis un péché
originel parce que vous avez voulu
supprimer l' isf en le faisant financer
par l'augmentation des taxes sur le
gasoil
je pense que c'est pas possible et vous
êtes je crois chefs d'entreprises donc
en tant que chef d'entreprise et vous
l'avez était donc en tant que chef
d'entreprise on peut peut-être et
essayer de se comprendre
je n'entends jamais dans votre bouche le
l'expression d'économies budgétaires
quand le sénat vous propose des
économies budgétaires vous détricoter
tout ce que nous faisons tout à l'heure
vous parliez du grand soir fiscal
mais tant qu'on ne fera pas d'économies
budgétaires tant qu'on ne fera pas
d'économies budgétaires dans votre
entreprise et dans la mienne vous savez
très bien qu'il ya le développement mais
il ya aussi la gestion laisser le sénat
mon parti politique vous propose je
voudrais vous faire aussi des
propositions pour vous demander votre
avis 20 milliards d'économies
budgétaires c'est possible avec 20
milliards d'économies budgétaires
vous pouvez vous pouvez supprimer l'isf
et je souffre je ne souhaite pas qu'on
le remette mais au moins supprimer l'
isf en le faisant financer par des
économies sans suppressions de services
publics sans suppression du service
public vous avez et nous savons le faire
et nous vous avons fait des propositions
et systématiquement vous re détricoter
ce que nous faisons et vous remettez les
dépenses
j'en termine le budget le budget 2010 8
qui vient d'être clos + 8 milliards
d'euros de déficit par rapport à l'année
d'avant
comment est ce possible de la part de
gens dont on espérait qu'ils allaient
gérer ce payer on alors
pour la première fois le déficit public
est descendu durablement en dessous de
3%
si vous le savez pas s'il s'y attendait
si on enlève ses prévisions la
croissance non bonne foi la
transformation du si c'est en baisse de
charges pérennes est un effet comptable
d'une année ce réseau innovant vous
dépenser 8 milliards de plus jamais
derrière j'ai un fils it la dépense
publique n'a augmenté aussi peu en
france vous le savez la vérité mais je
devais aller dans votre sens nous irons
plus loin
nous avons pris un engagement très clair
moins trois points de dépenses publiques
sur l'ensemble du quinquennat
simplement nous le faisons précisément
en transformant progressivement les
services publics nous ne voulons pas la
politique du rabot elle a atteint ses
limites
nous voulons transformer l'état les
administrations leur fonctionnement
précisément ce que je disais en première
partie d'émission pour que nous ayons un
meilleur service pour moins cher
j'aimerais une réponse sur la
proposition de réduction des déficits de
dépenses publiques mais ce que je pense
que 3 % ça ne veut rien dire pour les
réduire mais nous n'allons pas les
réduire de manière aveugle
nous savons qu commenter les derniers
temps mais si plus humiliant de nous
nous avons suivi méliand un déficit sur
l'ensemble du quinquennat baisser les
dépenses publiques d'environ 80
milliards d'euros
ce sera fait savait pas comment ces
lieux mais si nous avons commencé à
ralentir le mouvement vous savez quand
un bateau va très vite dans une
direction
il faut le freiner changer la direction
et on continue à les david habib un
autre témoin j'ai entendu j'ai entendu
une phrase tout à l'heure qui a été
prononcée par gilles legendre
nous souhaitons modifié nous avons
l'ambition de modifier nos pratiques
politiques démocratiques outre le fait
que j'ai assisté mais ça c'est chacun
administre son groupe comme il l'entend
j'assistais à à une engueulade de mardi
et dans l'hémicycle à l'égard d'une
députée qui s'apprêtait à ne pas suivre
la position du groupe
la république en marche quand même sur
la loi anti-casseurs outre le fait que
je
vous ai vu monsieur le député monsieur
le président du groupe lui rappeler à la
discipline de groupe
je le dis ici parce que vous avez voulu
réinventer la démocratie
jamais jamais un président de groupe
n'est venu me voir président du groupe
socialiste en rappelant que ce qui était
la ligne du parti j'ai souvent j'ai
refusé de voter un certain nombre de
textes qui me paraissait pas être
correct pour par exemple la réforme des
régions et jamais personne n'est venu
nous donner la leçon mais je poursuis
puisque vous voulez réforme et vos
pratiques politiques que nous apprenons
pratiquement tous les jours que le
dossier pénal a est différent que ce qui
avait été présenté initialement
qu'attendez vous pour demander à
l'assemblée nationale de faire son
travail d'investigation
pourquoi avoir pesé comme vous l'avez
fait sur les épaules de la présidente de
la commission des lois pour interrompre
un processus de recherche de vérité qui
était demandé par les français vous êtes
pour le nouveau monde
quand il s'agit de dénoncer ce qu'ils
étaient avant vous vous êtes surtout les
représentantes du néandertal c'est à
dire une vision figée fossilisés de la
politique autour d'un chef d'un chef qui
émaillaient le maquereau et si nous
étions ce que vous dites
il n'y aurait pas autant de diversité
autant d'expressions public varié et
c'est vrai particulièrement ce moment et
c'est vrai d'ailleurs et c'est très bien
comme ça
sur la taxe anti casseurs que que vous
ne le dites sur la sur la question
benalla axe pour une corde raide pour
une troisième fois pour une raison très
simple
maintenant la sphère benalla c'est une
affaire de faits divers quand la
commission des lois à siéger en
commission denquête c'est cela pouvait
être un fait politique parce qu'on
voulait comprendre ce qui s'était passé
l'hiver juste oui alors en panne on
attendait des accusations d'affaires des
parcs à partir d'un serveur à partir du
moment où alexandre benalla a été
licencié de l'elysée dans des conditions
absolument transparente et publique pour
tout le monde tous les faits qui sont
l'huile sont reprochés dupuis sont des
faits qui relèvent de l'enquète et de la
justice et donc le parlement n'a pas à
s'en mêler
ah oui c'est vrai
il ya une commission qui est toujours
sur la commission travaux jaune et la
leçon et navarro ces travaux oui mais
voilà l'état parlent ensemble moi j'ai
pas très envie de continuer sur cette
affaire là tellement et vous
effectivement dans le chapitre des
fédérés la dramatique pour l'état parce
que c'est pas une affaire comme ça mais
c'est je pense qu'il ya beaucoup de
l'enlever d'hier pour vous pardon ah ben
non c'est pas un fait divers mais je
veux pas utiliser mon temps de parole
pour faire ça et puis je veux pas
répéter ce qui a été dit moi je voudrais
vous venez pour prononcer le mot de
parlement je voudrais vous interrogez
vous est pris dans le groupe devrait
vous interroger sur ce que vous pensez
des fonctionnement du parlement
justement de nos institutions à titre
personnel ça n'engage que moi je
considère que notre vème république ne
fonctionne plus on donne tous les
pouvoirs à un seul homme le parlement et
élu cinq semaines après on a un
parlement croupion vous l'êtes nous
l'avons été tout dépend du président de
la république que l'on a
vous êtes amené à voter des choses
contre lesquelles vous aviez voté il ya
quelques mois sur l'ordre du chef par
exemple bob par exemple vous avez vous
jassy j'assimile le parlement députés et
sénateurs
l'exemple de la loi est là bas la loi
anti-casseurs les sénateurs de monsieur
macron voté contre senna et cette loi
est reprise à l'assemblée nationale il
ya eu quelque chose arrive juste à
castres les deux noms je termine juste
ma question pour dire est ce que vous
considérez vous en tant que président de
groupe qui serait pas utile c'est une
proposition aussi puisqu'on fait aussi
de débat sur les institutions est ce que
vous pensez qu'il serait pas utile de
rééquilibrer les pouvoirs du président
et du premier ministre donc du parlement
dans le sens d'une diminution des
pouvoirs du président de la république
pour redonner au parlement un peu ses
lettres de noblesse la vème république a
été très abîmée
est-ce que vous vous sentez à la tête
d'un groupe utile est ce que vous sentez
vous avez un peu la voix au chapitre ou
si vous avez le sentiment d'exécuter les
ordres qui vous viennent de l'elysée
alors je n'ai pas le sentiment
d'exécuter les ordres mais je vous
rejoins sur la nécessité de faire
respirer fortement le système est ce que
j'attends des suites du grand débat
national
c'est probablement une révision assez
forte de nos pratiques politiques qui
peuvent passer par la réforme
constitutionnelle mais pas que il n'ya
pas que il ya les réformes organique les
réformes ordinaire
il ya aussi des pratiques
institutionnelles je suis d'accord avec
vous sur l'idée qu'il ya deux ans je à
réussir un réquilibrage en effet entre
le rôle des parlementaires et le rôle de
l'exécutif donc vous ignorez vous
s'ouvre maintenant je sais ce que j'ai
l'air de souffrir kindle qui notre hymne
pas qui de ruine pas là guy que
représentera cédric last habituellement
nord pour la stabilité des institutions
et la deuxième chose qui n'est pas
contradictoire
c'est que nous fassions pas vous nous
fassions place à une démocratie
participative beaucoup plus vivante et
nous devons concilier la démocratie
représentative qui est le bien
indépassable parce que reposant sur le
suffrage universel et une démocratie
participative et quand je parle de
démocratie participative
je ne parle pas que de démocratie
directe certes on peut faire et j'ai
entendu dans la première partie ils
viennent ici ont fait 13 ans droguée
vous comment voulez-vous faire marcher
la démocratie participative
si la démocratie représentative c'est à
dire nous trois là ça marche déjà pas
mais c'est ce que je viens de vous dire
a donc c'est vrai que vous le fait dire
qu'il faut tenons nous passer par pertes
et profits tout je viens de dire le coup
on en attend des dons de laine annan
après le panneau dieter ai compris que
non mais je pense qu'avant de vouloir
faire de démocratie celi participative
il faudrait il faudrait en mai nous dans
notre démocratie à nous non ce réseau
des élus du rial sûrs selon les études
il ya urgence à traiter les deux en même
temps je vois david habib qui me
regardait avec des yeux
soupçonneux où ces petits persan je
pense que là nous avons tous un
aggiornamento profond à fait nous y
compris
vous avez dit majoritaire sur cette
thématique jeux pourquoi vous le
regardez comme ça je le regarde pas ce
que l'imaginaire façon d'abord voilà
bien évidemment et parce que j'ai en
face de moi
une lettre qui a été adressée à tous les
députés la république en marche de la
nouvelle aquitaine ma région
elle m'a été par un député
vraisemblement de la république en
marche transmise cette lettre où
l'auteur de ce courrier qui est député
de la vienne sacha oulié invité les
autres collègues ses autres collègues de
l'habitat match à une réunion le jeudi 6
décembre à l'assemblée nationale une
réunion je lis qui aura pour thème
principal jeu
j'habite à côté de moi l'interdît il a
vidé les questions électorales locales
bon pas de problème seul problème c'est
que étaient invités à cette région à ses
traits réunion tous les députés la
nouvelle aquitaine et monsieur le préfet
de région ligue et l'allemand 6 alors
cette réunion n'a pas eu lieu parce
qu'il ya eu la crise et j'ai des jeunes
mais la convocation n'a jamais été
contesté pas contesté par sacha ollier
qui a été interrogé par le groupe parce
que le projet d'un préfet s'est pas
d'assister à une réunion consacrée aux
échéances électorales
à l'initiative d'un groupe politique et
donner ce que je voudrais dire c'est
qu'on peut pas à oui ça veut dire que
vous êtes d'accord pour que l'effet soit
invité pour parler de redécoupage camp
depuis ses graves problèmes de vision
démocratique
c'est extrêmement grave mais jacques à
l'initiative de ce type de réunion nomi
dénommé gilles legendre un modèle de
fonctionnement démocratique de corée sur
la tête en respecter la répéter votre
parti qui m'est arrivé plus souvent qu'à
mon tour de voter pour lui donc de ce
point de vue là il n'y a pas de problème
non écoutez là vous cherchez vraiment la
petite bête vous êtes très très très
loin la préoccupation des français et de
l'enjeu que nous abordions depuis le
début de cette émission qui est en effet
un enjeu de pratiquer les murs atv
concrète si l'état prête nom votre
visite de la bécane accéder la mort et
hemani compris en trouverait parce que
vous n'avez pas au trou de là parce que
vous n'avez pas de troupes
vous demandez vous adosser sur le
travail des fonctionnaires et des
préfets mais je trouve scandaleux
scandaient d'adhérents que vous ne
réussissiez par rapport à ce type de
viande
combien d'avions ont droit aux délices
pc du charcutage électoral vous voulez
dire dans ces gens c'est ce que j'essaie
de combat je lis consacrée aux enjeux
électoraux alors qu'est-ce que vous
n'avez joli tout simplement qu'il la
présence du préfet de région
on n'est pas justifiée il lost on
convoque les autres députés de sa
formation politique on le fait entre soi
sans faire appel aux ressources
intellectuelles de l'état sujet majeur
écoutez tout ça ressemble à un petit
règlement de comptes entre amis de
gauche moi je ne suis pas dans cette
zone comprend enfin de croiser une et le
beaujolais de droite mais je ne coupe et
dre maroni c'est bien vous allez jouer
des macromedia grille a ajouté mme
mcmorrow suivre moi je voudrais revenir
une question qui qui qui est important
dans dans l'esprit des français qui
concerne qui concerne l'immigration et
notamment s'agissant parce que c'est
aussi ma recherche des droits du
parlement
nous proposons et je voudrais avoir
votre sentiment là-dessus puisque
l'immigration n'y voit pas très clair
est ce que vous ne pensez pas qu'il
serait bon comme le font d'autres états
que l'on puisse gérer l'immigration en
france que par exemple nous proposions
des quotas et que ce soit le parlement
chaque année qui débattent plutôt qu'on
apprenne comme ça tiens il ya encore 500
1000 cette année un million en cinq ans
seulement 90 % des immigrés en situation
irrégulière sont reconduits à la
frontière
moi je vous avais proposé 300 mille 300
millions d'économies
c'est pour ça que je parlais d'économies
tout à l'heure sur les immigrés en
situation irrégulière
puisqu'on est passé de 500 millions à 1
milliard pour l'aide médicale d'état
immigrés en situation irrégulière
tout ça est complètement opaque en même
temps qu'on diminue d'ailleurs les
crédits de l' agence française pour la
santé voyez voilà voilà comment on gère
en ce moment le budget pour moi est
vraiment quelque chose
le budget et larmes et larmes pour la
justice sociale dans notre pays et la
justice sociale c'est aussi quelque part
de comparer les comparaisons de
situation entre ressortissants français
et immigrés donc sur l'immigration ce
que nous vous proposons c'est des quotas
proposés par le président hervé cool
premier ministre un débat à l'assemblée
nationale et au sénat un parlement et un
parlement qui fixerait chaque année ce
quotas d'immigrés autorisés à venir en
france que nous choisirions en fonction
des capacités de la france à les
accueillir à leur donner du travail et à
leur donner aussi comme c'est le cas en
ce moment des allocations mais vous le
faites avec quelle finalité alain
joyandet pour faire des économies ou
pour faire en sorte que les émigrés
légalement présents sur notre territoire
soient mieux traités eh bien je fais
pour les deux parce que je vois ce que
coûte l'immigration clandestine
alors qu'on ne gère pas mal je vois ce
que coûtent les immigrés non reconduits
à la frontière ou partager je vois et je
vois ce que coûte et je vois ce que
coûte puisque vous me retourner la
question je vois budgétairement en tant
que forme de la commission des finances
du sénat
je vois ce que coûte l'immigration non
contrôlée puisque nous accueillons des
gens qui n'ont pas de travail et donc il
faut leur donner des allocations qui
bien souvent sont supérieurs à ceux qui
ont travaillé quarante ans et qui touche
une maigre retraite
est ce qu'on peut parler justice fiscale
si on ne parle pas de ça dans le grand
débat j'ai pas le sentiment qu'on en
parle alors qu'est ce que fait le
parlement alors je vous ferai remarquer
que la question de l'immigration a été
ajoutée au quatrième chapitre du grand
débat qui parle de la citoyenneté
ça a créé d'ailleurs un peu de polémique
mais je pense que nous avons bien fait
de le faire pour que les français
puissent s'exprimer sur un sujet qui est
à certains d'entre eux est extrêmement
sensible et à juste titre je vous fais
remarquer que nous sommes si convaincus
du fait que nous devons absolument
travailler l'intégration des immigrés et
des réfugiés et des immigrés
légalement sur notre territoire que nous
avons votée l'année dernière une loi qui
s'appelle asile immigration intégration
qui vise précisément à cet objectif
c'est à dire accélérer le traitement des
réfugiés et traiter correctement les
immigrés légalement installés sur notre
territoire ce qui passe ce qui passe je
vais jusqu'au bout du raisonnement et de
ce point de vue là je vous rejoins par
la régulation du nombre d'immigrés que
nous sommes capables de dire merci à
vous tous merci beaucoup ça n'est pas
une découverte une nana lorientais
s'était donc que sur les sept au juste
avoue juste un mot parce que c'est pas
tout à fait le même sujet mais je veux
juste avoir votre position là dessus
quelle est votre position sur l'éventuel
retour des jihadistes français sur le
sol national
écoutez là dessus le sujet est en train
d'être traités
nous appelons nous avons un vrai un vrai
problème avec al hilal à l'idée qu'ils
reviennent à la réalité de cette façon
de faire mais nous allons nous allons
nous allons trancher cette question très
prochain mais vous et moi je suis devenu
un homme
on en parlera quand on aura une solution
là on a pas d'évolution n'ont pour
l'instant non vous voyez bien la preuve
c'est que le débat est encore de ce fait
vous avez une position personnelle
généraux personnel mais les garde pour
un non je la garde pour moi
est-ce qu'ils doivent rentrer ou est ce
que je la garde pour moi c'est des
sujets sécurité nationale odile
subventions diplomatique à la dimension
humanitaire ces sujets là ne se règle
pas comme ça sur un plateau de
télévision
voilà vous êtes d'accord merci beaucoup
monsieur merci vous voudrez on a compris
monsieur gervais que vous êtes contre
l'idée de leur retour c'était son idée
voilà merci à tous les deux d'avoir
participé à cette émission merci et au
revoir
dernière partie donc avec nos deux
consoeurs qui font leur entrée sur le
plateau
avec nous donc brigitte boucher et
oriane mancini de lcp-assemblée
nationale et de public sénat bonsoir
mesdames une question tout de suite un
internaute du figaro qui vous demande
j'ai le genre
c'est beaucoup de me disent que la vème
république est en fin de vie est ce que
c'est également votre sentiment
la vème république à mon sens est à la
veille d'une assez grande évolution qui
ne tiennent pas l'affirmer pour passer à
la 6e elle est là elle a un atout
excellent exceptionnel c'est la
stabilité des institutions et ses
tattoos là il faut le préserver
en revanche comme je le disais tout à
l'heure avec mes collègues
parlementaires
il faut faire respirer le système
respirer le système dans la relation
entre l'exécutif et le parlement
respirer le système entre les élus que
nous sommes
ils enquêtent l'exécutif et le citoyen
brigitte l'écrivain et avocat françois
sureau donne une interview au monde daté
de demain qui est parue cet après midi
et il dit que la loi anti casseurs c'est
le citoyen qu on intimide est pas le
délinquant il parle d'une loi de la peur
est ce que c'est une loi contre les
libertés publiques
en aucun cas l'élu évidemment avec la
plus grande attention l'interview de
françois sureau qui est un très petit
est un très beau texte qui est un
prolongement d'un coureur qui est un
proche de nous ce qui prouve bien
quoi qu'on en dise que le droit à la
liberté de parole est parfaitement
respectée et que le régime de godillots
que décrit par le niveau d'atteinte à
leur france donc cette norme et je parle
cet habitant c'est un c'est un
très beau tech chacun de son rôle
françois sureau est un avocat et un
intellectuel nous nous sommes
responsables de nos concitoyens or que
se passe-t-il dans les manifestations
pas seulement depuis le début du gilet
jaune mais depuis des années c'est
l'immersion de violents d'adobe de
personnes violentes qui multiplient les
actes de très grande violence on en a eu
l'illustration pendant la crise des
gilet jaune et le droit des manifestants
de manifestation n'est plus adapté pour
traiter cela et si nous boulanger c'est
qu'on peut se passer d'un néon se passe
pas d'un jus
brigitte boucher l'article 2 lors de la
polémique préfets puissent décrété des
interdictions de manifester concernant
des zones dit exactement cent ans on
soupçonne les mauvaises c'est ce que
nous allons voter pas simplement les
mauvaises intentions à la certitude que
nous avons qu'il représente une menace
sérieuse pour l'ordre public c'est
exactement le terme de l'acte de dollars
mais avant même qu'il ait manifesté
parce que si on attend qu'il ait commis
l'acte
à quoi sert le dispositif ou s'il
fallait qu'il ait déjà commis un acte
à quoi servirait le dispositif mais le
juge mais nous tenons d'abord on
n'arrête pas on empêche de manifestants
maire jo la personne va agir dans le
sens que vous dénoncez à juste titre
évidemment
écoutez il défend pas les casseurs il
sait parfaitement qui est violent dans
les manifestations un des grands
avantages des situation actuelle c'est
que ces personnes sont très peu
nombreuses
très clairement identifiés très souvent
récidivistes et je veux revenir sur un
point que vous soulevez michel grossiord
vous dites on fait ça sent le juge
excusez moi c'est inexact le préfet
prend la décision
mais il est placé sous le contrôle du
juge
et elle préfère n'a pas envie de se
faire de retoquer par un jour donc quand
il prend sa décision elle doit être
lourdement argumenter sans quoi en effet
le juge rapportera un discours ne
convainc pas tout le monde dans votre
groupe c'était il ya des députés qui
aurélien tâche et matthieu orphelin et
d'autres qui ont annoncé qu'ils ne
voteraient pas cette loi est ce qu'ils
seront sanctionnés
en aucun cas s'ils s'abstiennent ce qui
manifestement et leurs intentions c'est
ce qu'ils ont dit publiquement
c'est ce que beaucoup d'entre eux m'ont
dit enfin beaucoup c'est très peu par
rapport à l'ensemble du groupe
mais toute voix et toute opinion pour
moi est intéressante et respectable bien
combien série d'abc vote aura lieu
demain
le vote aura lieu avec des échos
faisaient président du groupe j'ai des
échos je pense que si on est autour de
moins d'une vingtaine on sera dans les
pures c'est à peu près ce qui se sont
manifestés contre l'article 2
la semaine dernière mais vous savez je
ne suis pas là pour pratiquer la police
de la pensée
en dépit de ce que disait mon cher
collègue david habib tout à l'heure
cette année pas ça n'est pas ça le but
c'est quoi le but que l'on sait vous
restez dé rester les bras ballants
vouziers des contrats des eaux du camp
de vaud michel grossiord l'aimé bras
sont si peu ballan que pendant des jours
avec les commissaires de la commission
des lois et un certain nombre de députés
qui avaient décidé de s'investir sur ce
texte
nous avons travaillé à le modifier vous
savez que c'était un texte qui venait du
sénat que nous avons retravaillé pour le
rendre plus efficace le oui devait
l'être est plus protecteur des libertés
publiques
là où ils pouvaient pour certains
d'entre eux va encore assez mais moi je
suis l'homme qui sont en charge de
chercher l'équilibré et le compromis
c'est qu'il livre si la république en
marche quand vous êtes arrivé qui est
l'interdiction d'avoir une liberté de
vote ça veut dire qu'aujourd'hui il ya
une liberté de vote dans le groupe ne
soit pas le sujet de vote l'abstention
ça n'est pas un votre combat est votre
compte sur à des sanctions si demain il
a des votes contre il pourrait
fonctionner mais vous êtes obsédé par
les formations sur la volonté on n'est
pas comme ça on est pas des je suis pas
policier qui derrière chaque député et
qui est en charge de surveiller son dock
iphone in je ne peux pas dire que d'un
côté la démocratie doit respirer et
notamment la démocratie respirer entre
le parlement et l'exécutif et de l'autre
côté brandir la sanction à la moindre
écart de valeur morale et la france
certainement pas le mise sur l'esprit de
responsabilité de mes collègues
et sur ce plan comme je l'aï dit tout à
l'heure je ne suis jamais déçu
il n'y a pas une loi qui était proposée
par l'exécutif et dans laquelle nous
avons contribué à son enrichissement qui
n'ait été à vos côtés vous avez salué le
texte de la face et une interview de
l'avocat essayiste françois sureau dans
le monde paru diffusait un texte de
grande qualité effet le seul dont je ne
partage évidemment pas les opinions mais
vous savez c'est plus facile d'être
avocat et littérateurs que de gouverner
la france et notamment dans la situation
que nous connaissons actuellement
deux choses il dit qu'il ne voit pas le
progressisme à l'oeuvre aujourd'hui
surtout pas dans le domaine des libertés
publiques et il dit qu'il était choqué
quand des députés pensent aux députés la
pluie quand marche qui ont ironisé quand
ils ont entendu le député centriste
charles amédée de courson dire on en
revient à vichy et il dit j'ai vu d une
assemblée de suspects et une assemblée
de nains de jardin comment est ce que
vous avez lu ces phrases est-ce que vous
présidez un arôme qui ressemble à cette
définition d'un homme dans vos salué le
talent littéraire et les ducs j'ai du
mal à ne pas sourire parce que autant
d'excès c'est assez c'est assez navrante
et donc prenons le le genre pamphlétaire
dispose l'excès et bien françois sureau
il succombe
je reviens quand même j'ai beaucoup
d'amitié pour charles de courson qui
peut penser sérieusement que nous sommes
en train de voter une loi vichyste en
disant ça on voit parfaitement à quel
point ce reproche est infondé ça ne
tient pas la route
un seul instant vous savez il ya une
liberté publique très importante en
france vous savez laquelle à écouter le
son nom de la liberté de manifester est
ce qu'aujourd'hui vous considérez que la
liberté de manifester est suffisamment
protégé dans notre pays
dès lors que toute personne ça sert qui
manifestent risque de terminer avec un
oeil en moins avec un bras abîmé avec
des enfants terrorisés avec des choses
au tas c'est ça nous protégeons
aujourd'hui avec cette année nous visons
nous visons clairement les phares de la
remise en cause en la matière est pas
l'oeil en moins avec les balances qui
crée la violence des armes qu'ils ne
sont que récolte la tempête
nous voulons extirper la violence des
manifestations et les balles de défense
en les gardes
elles sont inutiles le jour où nous
aurons réussi à atteindre cet objectif
vous avez dit tout à l'heure on peut
s'exprimer on peut exprimer des opinions
différentes dans le groupe et est ce que
pour autant les positions
vendues par année style et notamment
contre la pma pour tout crime des
propositions des manuels macron est-ce
que ça ça ne porte pas préjudice au
groupe
et qu'est ce que vous comptez faire
comment vous comptez gérer ce qu'a
finalement anne est-il alors il est en
cours de règlement à la fois au niveau
du groupe et à la fois au niveau du
mouvement car il faut être extrêmement
précis
personne personne n'a envie de contester
a nié style le droit d'être contre la
pma si c'est ça qui anime ses
convictions jamais nous avons dit que
sur ces sujets bioéthique il y aurait
une liberté de vote au sein du groupe
la république en marche ce qui est
problématique c'est les types
d'arguments qu'elle utilise
à l'appui de ses convictions et là quand
il ya des risques de relents homophobes
quand elle parle de lobby lgbt à
l'assemblée nationale quand il ya des
relents potentiellement islamophobe ce
qu'elle conteste l'absence mais jauzion
décor voilà c'est légitimement perçu pas
la totalité d'entre nous comme traître
est contraire aux valeurs simplement ça
veut dire quoi ça veut dire ça veut dire
que je sais pas si cette cuisine
intéresse nos téléspectateurs mais je
peux le dire
le bureau du groupe a entendu à nier
style jeudi dernier et le mouvement va
l'entendre aussi dans le cadre d'une
procédure qui est prévu pour régler ce
genre de cas et nous verrons sur
quelques réflexions sur les ions cerise
passer des auditions pour l'instant nous
avons besoin de l'écouté d'échanger avec
elle nous avons eu cet échange au niveau
du bureau
le mouvement va procéder de la même
manière d'autres niveaux de ses
instances sur les réformes
on va parler de réforme parce que le
calendrier du parlement été quelque peu
modifiées par le mouvement des gilet
jaune par le grand débat en cours est-ce
que vous pensez que vous pourrez
continuer à réformer comme cela était
prévu mais c'est pas la question n'est
même pas savoir si c'est nous pouvons
nous allons le faire
nous avons été élus pour ça et les jets
les jaunes nous incite à aller encore
plus profondément dans la transformation
du pays
parce ce qu'ils nous disent c'est que
les choses ne vont pas assez vite que la
réalité concrète quotidienne
allemands des français les plus
vulnérables les plus fragiles ne change
pas assez vite
donc nous devons ont-ils changé mais pas
un mot réforme prévue c'est parce que
j'ai dit vous m'avez dit est ce qu'on va
pouvoir continuer à transformer je dis
oui nous allons continuer à transformer
et ce qu'il fout de la manière dont je
sais d accélérer dans certains cas
ralentir prendre le temps d'une
concertation approfondie nous verrons
armée sur l'esprit de transformation
nous ne céderons rien et pas par
entêtement à l'arrivée parce que c'est
faux la maintenir mais bien sûr parce
qu'elle est une condition de réformes
des services publics et elle est aussi
une condition de la réforme de la
situation des agents publics qui en
france ne sont pas heureux de leur
situation il faut maintenir la
suppression de san mames une
fonctionnaire au moment où les français
demandent plus de service public
il faut améliorer la qualité du service
public faire en sorte qu'ils soient
produits avec plus de numérique et faire
en sorte que ça soit plus performant
cela passera in fine et par des
réductions d'effectifs 120 mille postes
en moins sur le quinquennat la réforme
de la fonction publique ça a mécontenté
les fonctionnaires
vous n'avez pas peur qu'ils descendent
dans la rue emmanuel macron parle de
délibération permanente est ce que
finalement ce sera pas la manifestation
permanence cela fait un an que la
réforme de la fonction publique est
ouverte par olivier dussopt qui mène un
travail remarquable et qui passe par une
concertation quasi permanente
ce travail de concertation il va
produire des fruits c'est précisément
cette réforme et vous verrez que ce sera
une réforme acceptée parce que l'heure a
été négocié ce que vous dites qu'il faut
peut-être prendre le temps sur la
réforme des retraites par exemple est-ce
que le calendrier ça procès d'un homme a
tenu ses thèses notre exemple de modèle
de concertation et sera au parlement
avant l'été cette réforme des retraites
avant l'été ça n'est pas certain le
programme est extrêmement chargé
mais là par la réforme aura lieu et
notamment elle aura lieu quand elle sera
prête
c'est une réflexion étonnante mais ce
n'est pas encore un peu de temps que je
demande d'ailleurs le rapporteur du
texte ne dit qu'apple rapporteur le haut
commissaire le haut commissaire en
charge le haut commissaire il faut le
temps qu'il faut et donc une des vertus
de cette réforme c'est que précisément
on l'a prise par le bon bout
il reste plus
deux temps mais on n'a pas une question
finalement quel rôle vous allez leur
donner dans l'acte 2 du quinquennat
alors selon me lors de la première
montée alors d'abord il est faux de dire
qu'ils n'ont pas eu de rôle
c'est inexact tous les grands projets de
loi ont donné lieu à des concertations
intenses y compris les plus sensibles je
pense aux ordonnances travail qui était
le texte inaugural de notre quinquennat
mais c'est vrai que la question des
corps intermédiaires dans le
fonctionnement démocratique au moment où
on se pose la question de l'évolution de
nos pratiques démocratiques de nos
interventions ont testé doigts qui sont
contestés prenante du système voilà du
système qui sont fragiles qui sont peu
représentatifs
c'est quelques % de français qui se
reconnaissent dans les syndicats et ils
ont donc eu un taux d'abstention majeur
si on prend la comparaison avec les
votes politique
nous devons absolument revitaliser les
corps intermédiaires
alors certains corps existe déjà et sont
très dynamiques en france selon les
associations d'autres les syndicats ont
besoin de revenir dans le jeu
démocratique
c'est évidemment à eux de penser en
premier à la manière de le faire mais il
peut y avoir des dispositions que nous
pourrions discuter avec eux qui vont
d'ailleurs peut-être venir dans le cadre
du grand débat et qui consacrera leurs
rots consacreront leur rôle éminent dans
le fonction démocratique
vous êtes en train mais c'est pas un mea
culpa c'est pas moi qui suis responsable
des syndicats bondues douchez ce sont
les syndicats ces pour l'exécutif on
reconnaissons qu'il ya une auberge et
attend toujours un coup de fil du chef
de l'état depuis des mois d'études et ça
c'est là qu'arrive la vie ici est la
caricature lors du ccdh et laurent
berger a été reçu au mois de décembre
très longuement par le chef de l'état il
a été reçu par mon groupe parlementaire
le roman et nous étions très heureux de
le recevoir
parce que nous avons eu des échanges
extrêmement utile laurent berger je
crois a conscience plus que quiconque du
l'enjeu démocratique de la période que
nous vivons est donc il doit en être un
acteur extrêmement actif fait qu'on est
donc en effet nous devons l'associer à
nos réflexions
nous devons l'associer aux conclusions
que nous tirerons du grand débat et
surtout à la transformation démocratique
vallier mais il n'est pas le seul à
vouloir jouer ce rôle ni à devoir jouer
ce rôle
les européennes qui arrive dans moins de
quatre mois maintenant où on est voué à
la république en marge de la recherche
de votre tête de liste est ce que vous
avez enfin trouvé la perle rare
écoutez elle n'est pas connue
publiquement les passionnés connaissant
je ne la connais pas mais je pense qu'on
s'en approche à vitesse grand v la
question le portrait robot ne passe
certainement pas par la question du
genre mais en revanche la pureté de
l'engagement européen sa sincérité
ce sera un critère déterminant et c'est
lui qui mènera la campagne c'est
emmanuel macron non c'est clairement
l'équipe de campagne au sein du
mouvement qui est constituée que vous
connaissez il est évident que compte
tenu de ce que représente l'europe dans
la promesse que nous avons fait aux
électeurs en 2010 est constamment
renouvelée par un certain nombre de
discours clé qui ont montré que nous
croyons qu'il n'y a pas d'avenir en
france sans un avenir européen
entièrement repensé notamment qui
protège beaucoup plus qu'il ne l'a fait
les concitoyens européens
évidemment le président a une ligne un
cap évident à montrer mais n'avons pas
là est-ce qui participera à un meeting
comme l'avait fait nicolas sarkozy en
on n'en est pas encore à l'organisation
des meetings qu en revanche le président
est une parole forte sur l'europe
pendant cette campagne cela semble non
seulement évident mais hautement
souhaitais que vous redoutez que le
président tombe ce jour là non pas sur
son résultat aux européennes sur le
résultats des différents référendum à
questions multiples comme renzi en
italie est ce que c'est un risque en eau
que vous avez en tête en outre qu'un
inquiétudes en aucun cas n'ont en aucun
cas voir en aucun cas il ne tombera pas
pourquoi voulez vous qu'ils tombent sur
quoi sur les référendums non cominois
d'abord les référendum encore une fois
vous les à opti six pays n'ont pas été
dit ce n'est peut-être pas lieu le même
jour que le coach de l'abbr il n'en mais
vous revenez au début de notre avait
sonné
raison d'essayer michel grossiord reste
comme le voulait dit cette décision est
loin d'être prise blanc et sera prise le
moment venu tous ne pas en faire et de
le faire le 26 ou des chèques auraient
fait un an que vous vous considérez
qu'il faut démissionner ou pas parce que
ça va pas forcément de soi
non je ne crois en aucun cas compte tenu
des questions qui se profile sur le
référendum qu'il puisse avoir un
caractère publicitaire en aucun cas
surtout en plus si c'est des questions
multiples pas démissionné mais non bon
bon bon bon bon bon on attend votre tête
de liste me dis que ça vous dit que ça
arrive à la vitesse grand v ous et les
derniers quand même comme tard hervé et
comme ça ne sont encore plus regarder un
commentaire sur monsieur françois xavier
bel ami le philosophe présentait
toujours comme un catholique
conservateur choisi par aileurs ça vous
inspire une inflexion écoutez j'ai vu
que ses positions étaient tellement
clivante qu'il ait fallu le flanqué de
deux autres colistiers qui fasse trio
avec lui pour essayer d'atténuer
l'impact qu'il avait dans sa propre
famille c'est comme ça vous voyez le
lycée républicain
ben le début de lys c'est ça que j'ai vu
j'ai vu que la première réaction à la
nomination de monsieur bel ami étaient
des réactions négatives au sein de sa
propre famille on va essayer d'éviter de
faire cette bourde de l'anneau et
lorsque là vous nous lourd et d'avoir
attendu quelques semaines de plus très
bien on n'est pas en attendait pas que
ce moulin pour louer votre action sommes
là pour vous poser les questions ce
qu'on appelle le plus une heure avec
beaucoup de gilles jean merci diakité
merci est à nîmes
merci à vous l'exercice concernera la
semaine prochaine le ministre
l'agriculture didier guillaume qui sera
notre invité l'invité d'auditions
publiques mais raymond ministre de
l'agriculture
on lui dira avec votre part merci
mesdames merci à tous d'avoir été avec
nous ce soir à la semaine prochaine donc
[Musique]